tory's amazed been pretty firm hasn't
she that she doesn't think there should
be another brexit vote do you think
she'll get her way
well the government needs to bring its
steel back to Parliament as soon as
possible ideally early next week the
government withdrew it summarily at the
start of this week has given no reason
at all why it's not planning to bring it
back next week the Prime Minister was in
Brussels last week trying to get the
assurances and the changes to the deal
that she's been seeking but has been met
with a flat no it's no time for parlor
to move on we need to get on with it and
move this to a conclusion it's pretty
clear why they not bring it to the house
it because I lose it isn't it yes I mean
I think it's clear that the Prime
Minister is now running the clock her
strategy is to kick the can down the
road but it might be that's completely
unacceptable we can't be presented with
two bad choices her deal on the one hand
flawed fundamentally and the chaos and
disruption of No Deal we've got to do
better than that as a country and that's
why I think it's really important we now
go back to the people and ask them
whether they want to proceed with brexit
on the negotiated basis that the Prime
Minister is recommending or whether they
want to reconsider well let's talk about
the possibility of a second referendum
because there are reports around this
morning as I referred to in the dirt
into the introduction to the interview
that two of Tory's most closest allies
have been sounding people out have been
effectively wargaming and what happened
if there was a second referendum now
Gavin Barlow the chief of staff has
tweeted to say that he doesn't want a
second referendum what's your sense have
you been having conversations with those
two men well it's quite appropriate of
him to say he doesn't want a second
referendum no one of course would want
to have to reopen this question but the
reality is her deal is not going to be
acceptable to Parliament and we're going
to be presented with your turn today of
crashing out which is also unacceptable
to Parliament in that situation we're
going to need a plan B and I think the
best plan B is to go back to the people
and say we now know what brexit is
because we've spent two and a half years
negotiating this deal if you want this
deal it's available and we can do brexit
on this basis but if you don't you have
the option of staying in on our current
time so I know that that's what what you
think I'm interested know whether that's
what the cabinet thinks and whether
that's what the government thinks have
you had any conversations with people
that made you think that there is a
shift perhaps towards the possibility of
the second referendum well it's it's now
abundantly clear her deals not gonna get
through apartment we've been no changes
made to it in Brussels to make it more
acceptable to MPs said there are
conversations about well what is going
to have to come next and to my mind
there are very few other options that
are going to work so here those
conversations happening between them but
MPs are talking to each other all the
time and inevitably you're going to be
talking to two cabinet ministers as well
so of course MPs are talking about what
on earth were going to do we've spent
two and a half years negotiating a deal
which is going to be completely
unacceptable to partnered we have to
find a way through and to my mind going
back to the people and asking them to
give the final say on whether they want
to do brexit on this basis or not is the
right way to go so how many members of
the cabinet do you think will be open to
the idea of a second my friends look I
don't want to get into a numbers game I
think everything is fluid and I think
the moment that she takes the plunge and
brings her deal back to Parliament and
sees it defeated I think that will
clarify thinking for a lot of MPs and
cabinet ministers now you're pretty
clear in your support for another vote
you were born bred in London and you
represent hoping to own a constituency
in Greater London do you think you
really understand why people outside of
the Capitol voted to leave the EU and
the deep sense of betrayal that many of
those people would feel if that vote was
ignored and it was like I'm just gonna
do it again well I think this is the big
challenge we need to understand the
causes of brexit and why people voted as
they did and that includes people in my
own constituency who voted for leave
it's of course important that they are
listened to and we get to treat the real
causes of brac said and I don't I don't
think leaving leaving the EU said listen
I think the fundamental point is that if
we implement the Prime Minister's deal
that is going to be the ultimate
betrayal of the people who voted to
leave the European Union and the reason
for that is it does not deliver on the
promises of the 2016 referendum it will
not enable us to do trade deals of any
meaningful nature it will not enable us
to take back control on the contrary
we're going to be ceding control over
huge waves of our economy and have no
say at all in how they're made at the
moment we're an equal participant
in the structures of the EU we will
cease to be will be a passive rule taker
on the outside and lastly the people who
advocated brexit said we would have an
ability to turn ourselves into a sort of
a tiger economy on the edge of Europe
we're not going to be able to do that
under the deal she's putting forward the
Prime Minister's putting forward because
we will be will be taking all the rules
of the single market but we won't have
any say in how they're made anymore it's
a nonsense so what do you think should
be on the ballot paper if there was a
second referendum cuz I'll be honest
with you I've spoken to lots of people
who advocate a second vote and I seem to
be getting a different answer every time
Parliament will frame the question when
it legislates for a referendum to my
mind you've got a few options which
obvious you've got her deal the Prime
Minister's deal which has been
negotiated it's a 585 page legal treaty
with a 26-page wofully political
declaration but at least it's there
you've got our current arrangements
within the EU so that need remain
effectively and then I think the onus is
on the brexit ears who want a harder
form of brexit to define that for
themselves
it shouldn't be on the onus should not
be on people like me to define what hard
brexit is if they want to advocate in
Parliament for a WTO style relationship
fine then they can make the case in
Parliament and get that question on the
ballot paper as well but the onus should
be on the heart breaks it is after two
and a half years to define what they
actually mean I think it tells you a lot
about the lack of clarity and the lack
of plan on the hard brexit site the two
and a half years into this whole project
we still don't actually have a clear
answer from the hard brexit team as to
what they would actually like to see
well I think some of them may argue that
it would be you know leaving on WTO but
others who are arguing for super Canada
Canada plus plus plus
I mean it's they're not exactly the same
they're variants of of each other but
they're not the same okay
and now the you've been pretty scathing
of her deal and the Prime Minister faced
a confidence motion in Parliament how
did you go I don't comment on leadership
I took a decision when I entered
Parliament in 2010 that I was never
gonna comment on leadership questions
not least because people would assume as
sort of bringing family issues into it I
don't want to get dragged into any of
that and I'm not gonna start now okay at
the same time though and it's quite
difficult to separate the prime minister
from
policy are you worried that she's not
really listening enough to the concerns
or parliamentarians yes I am worried
that's why I think it's really important
that she brings the debate back we
suspended a five-day debate after three
days we've got to continue that debate
next week
on Monday or Tuesday or Wednesday have
the vote on her deal said that we can
all move on and then move on to the next
step of this process which is to ask the
public whether they want to go ahead and
do brac sit on this negotiated basis
that we spent two and a half years
preparing if they want to do that fine
we can go ahead with the Prime
Minister's deal and implement that but
we can't waste any more time we've got
precious little time left and the time
for fantasy decisions fantasy in
renegotiations of the package to sort of
get to Canada plus plus plus or Norway
plus or all these other different
variations that are out that that time
has come and gone we've got a deal on
the table it's the only deal on the
table and now is the time for Parliament
to decide and then to put it back to the
people for them to confirm whether they
want to do brexit on that basis or not I
mean you're saying Norway's fantasy you
say Canada's fantasy I mean is that the
Prime Minister's current deal a fantasy
and that it won't get through part
neither
well the Prime Minister still has the
virtue of at least having been
negotiated it's got many many floors and
it's not not in our national interest to
do it the other schemes Canada plus
Norway plus they haven't even been
negotiated we don't even know whether
they could be negotiated in certainly in
any and any relevant timeframe and I
think the time has come for us after two
and a half years to try and give
certainty that people in my constituency
in Orpington are looking for businesses
all over the country are looking for and
to put this to rest once and for all and
now you mentioned to these passing
interviews asking you about family
issues so I'll apologize in advance for
my next question but in an interview
yesterday you said of your brother Doris
Johnson who campaigned to leave the EU
his force of personality papered over
the absence of any deliverable plan so
do you think that breaks that wouldn't
have happened then if it hadn't been for
your brother well I think he was a very
prominent campaigner for brexit and I
think he played a part in getting the
country over the line there's no no dad
my dad he and others like Michael go
and and other other big prominent
figures of the leave campaign yes of
course they were really influential in
the debate um and of course Brax that
has been pretty divisive issue for many
families do you think there'd be a few
awkward moments Johnson family this
Christmas
actually we're united as a family right
now in dismay at the deal that's on the
table from the government our priority
my priority is to ensure that we don't
take an irrevocable step by accepting
this bad deal it's not in our national
interest and I think it's really
important we think again before we do
that okay
jeh Johnson thank you very much